[Music]
fred is with us in san antonio hi
fred how are you i'm good uh
just a quick question um i have
a house that during the divorce uh was
given to the
ex uh it's 135 thousand dollars but the
loan is in my name
the divorce was three years ago uh and
my fiance and i we went through the dave
ramsey
a financial peace class and paid off 38
000 in
10 months good for you uh and uh
right now we're trying to get a house
ourselves
but we are hesitant on doing that
because of this other loan that's over
over my head uh you know we don't know
so the divorce decree was your divorce
lawyer sucked
because he left you without the house
and with the loan
correct uh well the the the paperwork
says that each one has to pay for their
debts so i was i'm
i don't i'm trying to move forward with
trying to force
i don't know forcing her hand to do that
well that that's you know the mortgage
should have been addressed in the
divorce degree it wasn't
yeah it wasn't that's weird
yeah okay so basically you don't have
anything from the divorce decree to help
you
uh you you you did a quick claim deed on
the house and so you gave up your
ownership right
correct okay and that was part of the
divorce decree or just part of the
negotiation
uh the part of the divorce decree what's
on paperwork
okay then i suspect the divorce decree
addresses this mortgage but i suspect it
just says you stayed on it
and it didn't ask her to refinance
within a certain period of time correct
correct which is what should have
happened all right so for those of you
listening if you go through a divorce
god help you but if you do
for god's sakes get the mortgage out of
your name that's part of the settlement
make the person keeping the house
refinance it into their name
and so that you don't end up where he is
stuck do you remember what the interest
rate is on the mortgage
it's 4.5 okay well the current market is
somewhere around three
do you have any money uh
i uh my fiance and i both together have
about 14 000
saved up okay number one you don't buy a
house with a fiance
you wait or you're married okay okay
because you're gonna get yourself in yet
a different kind of mess
all right but once we're past that the
only way out how's your
how's your relationship with the ex are
you on speaking terms
we are on speaking terms we are on
speaking terms
kids involved yes sir okay
so she does not have any reason to
refinance this mortgage
except that she could get a lower
interest rate
right so one way to settle this
might be to offer to pay her refinance
costs
if she will go ahead and refinance that
way she gets a lower interest rate
you get your name off the mortgage okay
okay probably cost you three grand okay
i'm guessing but i mean if you could
talk to her about that and say listen
you're
this is a deal for you you get a cheaper
interest rate and it doesn't cost you a
thing
i'll pay the refinance costs to get my
name off of it
so that i can go buy a house with my new
wife
right and that that sets you free it's a
good deal for her
and it's a the end of a bad deal for you
which is also called a good deal
[Laughter]
so and then you know and then save up
some more money make sure you have your
emergency fund in place you're debt-free
you have a good down payment before you
talk about buying your married oh yeah
yeah i don't want him paying off the
ex's house for fun that's not a good
time
let's make sure we look at the fine
print in that decree and and like you
said see if that she can refinance and
take that loan and
it's a good deal for everyone involved
yeah the decree would allow her to
refinance it but it probably doesn't
require her to
um so again uh
it's a divorce attorney
that's lazy they mail it in
okay and it happens every day tens of
thousands of times a day
and the bottom line is okay we're gonna
split the house mama's gonna keep the
house
but uh we're gonna put the house in her
name she gets all the equity and so
you're going to deed the house
over to her and we forget the idea that
he's still on the mortgage so you have
to require
whoever's going to stay in the house in
this case mama to
uh to refinance or we sell the house one
of the two but don't stay
on the mortgage and not keep the asset
as part of your divorce
it's a raw deal man well you're out of
control you don't control anything
you know let's say that she didn't want
to speak to him under any circumstances
there's nothing he can do man he's stuck
yeah i'd fix this thing while they're on
speaking terms yeah exactly